former vice presidential candidate
and former governor of alaska sarah
palin a big trumpist
was interviewed by good morning britain
and it is
absolutely nuts and you know i jokingly
said
10 days ago on twitter remember when
sarah palin was the craziest person in
the republican party back in 2008
and how now she seems so moderate
compared to some of this wacky q and on
stuff
then i saw this interview from yesterday
and now i'm thinking no no sarah palin's
just as wacky as a lot of these q anon
people
let's look at some of some clips here
we'll dive right in first question to
sarah palin was
does trump bear responsibility for the
january 6th
riots the president told uh
those who are attending the rally to go
protest peacefully and patriotically
and legally so no we're so these idiots
who did storm the capital um
and now they're blaming the president
for their own actions i think that's a
symptom
of a societal problem where people just
cannot take responsibility for their
stupid and criminal acts the hilarity
of sarah palin saying this is about
people being unable to take personal
responsibility for their actions
that's what started this entire thing
that's what got us here
if on november 8th which was the day
that the media
called the election for joe biden if on
november 8th
donald trump and republicans took
responsibility and said
we lost we failed on covet and we lost
or we didn't do
for whatever reason we lost and that's
it that
responsibility would have prevented all
of this
and of course after the fact in trump's
inciting of the riot as well they
are completely denying any
responsibility whatsoever but that
personal responsibility
is not what sarah palin is talking about
she says that the problem with personal
responsibility
is the people who did the rioting aren't
taking personal responsibility
then sarah palin makes the case that
listen the rioters were already there
planning chaos
they weren't influenced by donald trump
at all and piers morgan points out well
hold on a second
the two months of the lie about election
fraud from november 4th
that was really the initial catalyst for
these people being
so whipped up to begin with this is why
they were even there
on january 6th it's a very good point
sarah palin doesn't like it
also you have to remember that those who
were these writers and again they were
horrible and they had it was a horrible
act um
they were there already so many of them
were they were
like standing in the back of the rally
um root non-patriotically
a president's speech no they were they
knew what they were going to do
they were going to go storm the capital
and
be jerks yeah the reason they were going
to sarah the reason
sarah palin were going to do that is
because the president ever since the
result of a fair democratic election had
perpetuated an absolute lie
that there had been widespread fraud
which has never been proven
at all it didn't exist he whipped his
mob into a frenzy he told them to stop
the steal
and as the elected officials in congress
were actually ratifying the election
he ordered them to march down to the
capital and stop the steal
and yeah some of them may have just got
the wrong memo but you know what it
sounded to me
like the president wanted to stop the
steel as he put it and stop the
democratic election
being ratified that i'm afraid is a
criminal action isn't it
why are you generalizing though and
making it sound like it was this entire
crowd that was so
excited
now this is just rich why are you
generalizing
she says well he's not generalizing 75
million people voted for trump
piers isn't talking about 75 million
people because most of them stayed home
on january 6.
thousands and thousands of people went
to the january sixth
trump rally piers also isn't talking
about all of them because some of them
when the rally was over turned around
and they went to their cars or got on
the subway and went home where they came
from
he is doing the opposite of generalizing
he's talking specifically about the
people who went to the capitol
and were trespassing and vandalizing and
being violent was it 500 people was it
1500
people 2 000 we're still trying to
figure out the exact number
he's not generalizing at all and this
continues
and sarah palin won't even concede that
donald trump lost and this is where it
you really see the full delusion of
sarah palin
and i know some people are going to
write to me and say david she seems
unwell
she just she seems like she's not well
uh and unfortunately
this is the impression we get from a lot
of these right wing loons
so i don't know that that tells us much
one way or the other about her politics
but
she was asked trump want trump didn't
win right like trump lost
and she says well i don't know take a
look sarah i saw
thousands of people i'm not generalizing
we all saw the scenes
no i watched thousands of people
storming
into the capital we all watched it with
our own eyes it was one of the most
crowd right okay i'm talking about the
thousands who did
and there's no question there's no
question they were whipped up to do so
because they believed their president
who told them the election had been
stolen fraudulently stolen that was a
lie wasn't it
uh the president has been insisting so
many americans have been insisting
that our elections are run um
legally and uh transparently
and when there were shenanigans
obviously in um
so many of the polling areas the
president
has insisted that we look into
where all these votes had come from the
election wasn't stolen was it sarah
palin let's be honest just be clear
the election the election was won sarah
the election
the election was one let me just say
something and there are always this
sarah the election was won the election
was won
fair and square by a thumping win by joe
biden do you accept that
uh i want to see that our elections
and every polling place is run cleanly
now i was a governor
so she will not admit that in trying to
defend trump
from any blame about people storming the
capital
she's doing the exact thing that started
all of this to begin with which is
she's now been asked twice did trump
lose
and she's not answering the question and
it continues
the question was do you accept the
election victory
by jova by crazy you guys invited me to
come on
because it's just that you didn't answer
that part of the question you didn't
answer my question if you want to if you
want to finish
okay why do you answer the questions now
i'm talking about
clean elections and i know that
shenanigans do take place
in elections as a governor i witnessed
that
also and we were always having to crack
down through division of elections and
the lieutenant governor's office and he
answered the question
the bureaucrats who are in charge of it
because for instance
we had um barack obama's right-hand man
let's not talk about obama he hasn't
been obama's not been officers
sarah you can't filibuster us
now listen let's go back to the question
the question was do you accept
the joe biden okay let's go okay let's
no let's go back to let me ask you a
question
and you and you answered my question
look did joe
go back to the first question did joe
biden did
did joe fight let me try and answer a
question
absolute hysteria it's it's incredible
that there are
layers of hysteria here that
we're unable to even get to because she
won't get through the first
level of hysteria like allowing the
question
to simply uh uh be repeated and then
giving an
answer did joe biden win here's one more
attempt
the rioters on the day of joe biden win
the election
can we please finish what the topic why
did you just skip on over there because
it's about the
thoughts of the issue isn't it the
president who is facing impeachment
if he was solely to blame for these
criminals
and their i believe he was to blame for
the criminals but i'm asking you
sarah palin whether you believe joe
biden won the election
well evidently he did because he's sworn
in as our president
but no one will convince me nor anyone
else with common
sense um and a sense of justice
uh no one will convince us that there
were not shenanigans
going on what are the shenanigans
explain to me what the
given that nobody is nobody can argue
the numbers give him an
argument sarah politician but you cannot
argue against the facts
given that nobody has produced any facts
to prove
there was widespread forward in the
election do you have it now can you show
us
can you tell me where's the spot
now don't interrupt me while i finish
this point okay
listen how many polling areas
had to produce their voter rolls
and they showed that there were say more
votes than there were voters in certain
districts
where's the fraud
is that where is the single court where
is the single
where has a single court in america
upheld fraud okay
you're asking if there was fraud i'm i'm
telling you where the shenanigans were
what about all the dead people who voted
where was that held in court i don't
know sarah we like you on this program
sarah i like how piers says he likes her
on the program i find her completely
insufferable
and corrosive to american politics he
likes her okay
more votes than people wasn't
demonstrated anywhere just because they
repeat it doesn't make it true
and then dead people voting come on it's
been so widely debunked every time it's
been investigated dead people voting
were actually
a combination of people who were
registered
but died before the election and didn't
vote being registered to vote and then
dying and not voting
isn't a crime it's not shenanigans it's
not foul play
uh clerical errors some junior senior
confusion where like a junior voted
and the vote was counted as their dad
who might
have been uh dead at the time of the
election but it was still only one vote
it just counted for the wrong person
that's another thing that happened um
and then also
when uh i believe it was channel 4 in
the uk
did an investigation about this a lot of
the people that were
just claimed to be dead were actually
just alive and that's happened to me
remember i was featured in a documentary
about people who were supposedly dead
and i had to put out a statement saying
i am i am very much alive right now so
that is um these are all uh untruths
and this went on and on there probably
about another five or six minutes of it
i won't play more
but absolutely horrifying that
sarah palin was very close to being the
vice president
of the united states and had she been
vice president she would have been as
the phrase goes
a heartbeat away from being president of
the united states
really scary stuff i'd rather her saying
crazy things in alaska
than in the white house for sure but
that doesn't make what she's saying any
less
outrageous we'll have more of this
including commentary your commentary
on the david pakman show instagram make
sure you're following us there
at david pakman show we'll take a quick
break and be right back
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid 19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to health care institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping
is free on orders over a hundred and
fifty dollars you can get there by going
to davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david